The most dangerous and advanced APTs
are those that use a zero-day exploit or
a specially crafted malware.
A zero-day exploits a previously
unknown vulnerability and
therefore there's no patch or
fix for the vulnerable system.
And most likely there's no prevention or
detection signature for the attack.
That is, a zero-day exploit
will succeed and go undetected.
Likewise, a specially crafted malware
is usually designed to defeat
the signatures and
behavior patterns in a detection system.
That is, it also has a very high
chance to succeed and go undetected.
APTs are characterized by its ability to
not only evade anti-malware and network
intrusion detection systems, but also
fool even the most sophisticated users.
For example,
an APT can be designed to first
compromise an internal network router or
server and all it does at that point is
to learn about the valuable individuals.
That is, the APT will first learn who's
e-mailing to whom, on what topic and
with what kind of
attachments in the e-mail.
With such knowledge, the APT can then
forge email from a person to another.
And this email can appear
to be very legitimate.
This is so-called,
Spear Phishing because it is
targeted to a specific individual.
And if the internal network, router, or
server has been compromised, the APT
can play man-in-the-middle to make such
social engineering attacks very
successful and very convincing.
For example, if the email recipient is
not certain about the email attachment,
and he sends an email to the sender and
asks hey did you send this?
The APT can pay the man in
the middle to intercept inquiry and
send answer back to the user
to say yes I sent this.
APTs are also designed to plan in with
normal activities to avoid detection,
even if that means it
has to go low-and-slow.
For example, if an APT is designed to
forge a document, it will not do so,
unless the user is also
authoring another document.
Similarly if the APT is designed to
send our document it will not do so
unless the users also
sending our document.
As another example if the APT is
designed to change the setting off
a controller in a nuclear plant, the APT
does not make the changes all at once.
Instead, it will make incremental
small changes over time
to accomplish the eventual attack goal.
For example, the famous Stuxnet
falls into this example, and
you can search and learn more about it.
And because APT activities are designed
to blend in with normal activities and
go low-and-slow, it is very hard for
an anomaly detection
system to catch an APT.
APTs are often designed to stay in the
compromised organization for long time.
For example, always looking for
more valuable data to steal.
For example, an APT can include
a number of steps, and at each step
you only focus on a subset of the users,
and only part of the network.
And at each step, he may actually use
a different version of the malware.
And when it moves from one part
of the network to another,
it may clean itself from the O port.
That is, at any given it's only
present at the specific target.
In other words,
it's footprint remains to be very small.